the world is in chaos and the media
knows just the man to solve it despite
two Wars raging in Ukraine and Israel
are troops coming under attack 73 times
in the Middle East and China setting its
sights on Taiwan Democrats and the
liberal press say thank God Joe Biden is
the leader of the Free World I also like
to step back uh when I see some of the
heat President Biden is taking and think
what would the alternative be can you
imagine what the scenario would be in
the Middle East it would probably be the
United States and Israel in a World War
II like scenario the world could really
spiral into World War I but it's not
because a guy who's actually had 50
years of
experience all right so the media thinks
the man whose own staff has a bubble
wrap strategy to protect him from
falling in public is the one person
keeping the world from the brink of
Armageddon all right Jesse so we should
be grateful that our troops in Iraq and
Syria have only been hit I think 74
times and Thursday an intercontinental
ballistic missile and uh about half of
the 66 injured have traumatic brain
injury which last for life so as long as
we play py and lie down we're saving the
world it's a pretty low
bar I am not bringing back the draft
Biden
20124 running on not starting World War
II that's that's the lowest of the low
bars meanwhile Joe Biden is telling
fundraisers nuclear Armageddon is the
highest risk since the Cuban Missile
Crisis he's invoking himself World War
III dozens of times and we got a land
war in Europe we got a hot war in the
Middle East we got a Cartel War this
place is going nuts we just tested a new
nuclear weapon in Nevada he deployed
additional soldiers to Europe meanwhile
Donald Trump I think was the first
president a very long time not only to
not initiate a new war but to not send
additional troops to a theater so to say
that oh he's going to just break out
into the World War III doesn't make
sense when you consider what happened
that term you know um
Dana right now we're hearing that that
there are 10 hostages or a 10-month-old
Israeli boy in the family have been
moved by Hamas to another terrorist
group I think the P the Palestinian uh
Islamic jihadist in the West Bank and I
understand I mean I'm told that that's
because they're getting information from
the hostages and they're getting
intelligence so where does that put us
when even they are not together in terms
of where these hostages are I just I
can't imagine like if I was there in the
oal office I just imagine and I'm not
and I don't have the weight of all of
this and I understand that there's lots
of different considerations but a
10-month-old baby being these are such
monsters and the fact that we were not
able to get proof of life so that means
that Hamas now can have even more
extreme emotional blackmail against all
of the families and guess what else they
get negotiations for a further ceasefire
as they continue to rearm also while we
were on the air at 512 today Jennifer
Griffin from the Pentagon tweeted this
that there's a report that an Iranian
drone flew near the USS Eisenhower in
the Persian Gulf today November 28th and
it was in international waters the
Iranian drone ignored multiple warnings
from Ike the Pentagon this is the quote
is deeming this interaction unsafe and
unprofessional yeah yeah absolutely so
this is not something that we are
provoking they are provoking us and at
some point there will be a reaction and
I hope that it's the right one and I I
don't envy them for all of the things
that are going on but a lot of the
policies led to a lot of this so I think
that when they talk about all of their
accomplishments a lot to me a lot of
their accomplishments in the Biden
Administration are also their
vulnerabilities going into the election
you know Greg these are the same people
who think the way you commented
yesterday that isn't it great that Hamas
is releasing the hostages without even
considering what happened on October 7th
it's like there's this this Veil that's
covering what the Acts were well that's
why they they will be perpetually
involved in this endless cycle of Tit
for Tat because they look at people as
evil as opposed to the acts of evil if
you if you if you describe each Act
independently as good or evil and
obviously October 7th is evil then you
cannot justify it but as long as you say
those people are evil then you can talk
about history and context and ah open
air prison and all this other stuff
that's been going on for 60 years that's
why they don't do it I don't think Joe
Biden's gone far enough under his watch
we've had no World War III we've had no
bubonic plagues we've had no alien
invasions I mean from outer space that
is Jessica and also we've had no zombie
apocalypse so in that context who cares
if we have a Relentless crime wave or a
collapsing education system or a
military and police in Decline Rising
anti-americanism uh real estate collapse
you know a transportation system in
total disarray from Planes Trains to
EVS E I still can't get an EV Bentley
that's a call back anyway we got open
borders we got inflation we got two Wars
but again no Bubonic plague no World War
III no space aliens no zombie apocalypse
I think on the whole it's a win-win yeah
and they think so too yes Jessica if you
were handling the
negotiations what what would you
want I I would want everybody out right
away in some sort of negotiation for
territory and control I'm sure is what
Hamas would want in exchange for this um
and that seems to be a bit of the
sticking point that we've seen in the
past couple of days reports have been
coming out of Israel that BB has been
talking to people within the government
saying you know I'm the only person
who's going to be able to maintain
control over the West Bank and Gaza
after all of this is over and we get the
hostages out and and that's what it is I
mean this has been the fight since the
Inception of modern day Israel after
World War II um and I won't say that I'm
surprised because I have spent enough
time around the table with you guys to
know how you think about this but it's
incomprehensible to me to to blame Joe
Biden for this I mean if you want to
talk about a world leader who turned
their back on a pressing concern about
what's going on in the Middle East let's
talk about BB Netanyahu and that he
spent the eight nine months before this
attack happened having to send troops to
the other side of the country because he
wanted to overhaul the Judiciary to keep
them in office forever and completely
gut their version of the Supreme Court
over 80 80% of Israelis have a negative
view of him people in his own
Administration have taken responsibility
saying we ignored signs whether it's the
report from Egypt or the fact that it
will take you a couple years to build up
what Hamas has managed to do so Joe
Biden his standing on the world stage in
terms of what world leaders think of him
is up what people in other countries
think is up and I think it's dereliction
of Duty this narrative that's going on
in the media and and certainly in the
liberal media where they just want to
crap on him because if you look at like
the morning console poll the first poll
taken since the ceasefire began came out
first major poll Biden's up four points
and is now up one over Trump there was a
Yuga poll out last week that had Biden
up over Trump the New York Times Santa
poll which we gave its due and we talked
about the fact that Biden was down and
he was losing the swing states in the
cross tabs and the New York Times didn't
even cover this part of it the cross
tabs revealed that if Trump is convicted
of anything and he has 91 counts that
he's facing he loses by 10 points and he
loses every single that got to do with
what would you do to negotiate to get
the host I
answered we're not talking about Donald
Trump two points in the real in the
average I didn't but my point is
that that's not the topic you always say
that's not the topic because you go off
topic let's not talk about who goes off
topic here really it but it is relevant
because you start out by saying this guy
is a and we're in a hot War here
and a cold war here and the bord open
and whatever so I'm talking about what's
going on on the ground no no I'm talking
about the general Jessica we have not
had a zombie apocalypse let's just
remember that yeah how do you know have
you seen
MSNBC you know what it's unfortunate the
way this President cares about soldiers
is enabling more attacks on our what are
you talking about but I'm talking and
I've made a statement and coming I made
a Here We Go Again hi everyone I'm Brian
kilme I want you to do me a favor I want
you to click to subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube page this is the only way
that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now